We can always simplify powers of i since the pattern continues to repeat
itself. To find any power of i we simply divide the power of i by four and look
at the remainder. The remainder will either be 0, 1, 2, or 3 and will determine
the power of i. For example i to the 12th, we would take the power of 12 and
divide it by 4. We know 12 divided by 4 equals 3 with a remainder of 0. This
remainder becomes the new power for i. So we know i to the 12th is really
equivalent to i to the 0, and anything to the 0 power equals 1. This should
also make sense since i to the 12th can be written as i to the 4th, times i to
the 4th, times i to the 4th. This means we really have i to the fourth repeated
a bunch of times, or really just the multiplication of positive 1. It's easiest
to simplify any power of i by dividing the power by 4 and looking at the
remainder, this will be our new power of i. Once we have our power of i, we
look back to see what it would equal. In this case, we don't need to, since we
have i to the 0, and anything raised to the zero power equals 1. We know our
pattern repeats every 4. So if we worked backwards with our pattern. We know i
to the 0 would equal positive 1. So this should definitely make sense with our
pattern. So, if I wanted to simplify i to the 39th, I would do 39 divided by 4.
We know this is 9 remainder 3. This is what I'm interested in. The remainder.
So I know i to 39th is really equal i to the third power. We're going to cycle
to this pattern of four. Nine times and then ended up with i cube. We know i
cubed is really equal to negative i. So this power simplifies to negative i. If
I want to simplify i to the 50th. I would divide 50 by 4 which is 12 remainder
2, so I know i to the 50th is really equal to i squared or negative 1.